top three movies every actor should
watch and which performance they should
study that's like in terms of acting
doesn't mean story but whether it's
Glengarry Glen Ross whether it's network
I mean just in terms of acting and
performances okay I'm gonna okay top
movies and top performances are two
different categories okay talk
performances let me live performances
blue Jasmine okay yeah a pleasure
because that was that was to me it was a
stunning performance because in terms of
the way I work I think there are certain
actors when I say actors can't do this
alone there are some actors who have
these amazing abilities to allow
themselves to sink deep into a character
Cate Blanchett is one of them and blue
Jasmine's one of those performances
almost regardless of what you think in
the movie just watch her work and the
multi-faceted ways because of different
timeframes that she had to experience
that character another actor Daniel
day-lewis is similar if you look at his
work in Lincoln or gangs in New York or
something he's another actor who has
found a way of dropping himself deeply
into a character and one very quickly
when an interview I read about him not
with him and actors who worked with him
and asked him at the end of the movie
because she couldn't talk to him during
them will because he was in character
all the time
asked him why he spent so much time as
so much energy just to get into a
character like that and his answer was
he says I'm not a good enough actor to
do it any other way which I thought was
profound he sees himself as a very
limited actor and but he knows what he
needs to do to get deep into that
character if you watch manchester by the
sea casey affleck s-- performance i
think is stunning regardless of his
history his background and the problems
that he has watch that performance
because there's another actor who has
dropped so deeply into the nuances of
the characters it's sort of a sort of
startling meryl streep will do this
frequently
freak Li she's only been nominated 20
times but I mean there's certain so
there are certain actors who you watch
them and they can literally disappear
you feel that the character takes on and
that's that's that's what we're looking
for
chameleons chameleons in a way but I I
see it as a more than chameleon
chameleon is more like I will change
myself into something so which it is
chameleon like but it is I will release
mice I will give myself over to say this
is my experience my experience of these
actresses they give themselves over and
just allow themselves to be in that
world with in a way ignoring themselves
regardless of what happens to them as an
individual as an actor they have to be
that it's a total relinquishment to the
character and if someone were to watch
let's say those performances from those
four or five actors that you mentioned
what about turning down the sound and
just seeing the body language yeah the
reactions expressions of
micro-expressions yeah exactly
yeah watch them in detail just watch
them yeah try and watch the movies which
which else should I do we could have a
whole discussion about that watch it
several times and watch and even stop
and look at me and go back and just look
at that moment look at just look at that
reaction and understand that with the
best performance that reaction was not
planned that stunning reaction probably
was not planned at all it just happened
I remember I was working with an editor
who I've worked with in a couple films
of mine he was showing me a film that I
didn't direct seen and there was a
stunning moment that's seen he says you
know that's the only time she ever did
that and that to me was a key thing
that's you know to capture those moments
that happen but first of all the actor
has to allow themselves to give that
unplanned planned performances are death
unplanned performances over swear the
gold is just go in there and just see
what happens
you